[Musique]
en ce dimanche de fête des mères à
l'invitation du département de La
Réunion dans les couloirs et le jardin
du centre d'hébergement du rosier rouge
les mamans et les papas sont à l'honneur
bonne fête des mamans
aujourd'hui c'est d'être aux côtés des
Réunionnais parfois certains malades
sont en métropole depuis un long moment
pour ne pas ressentir cette sensation
d'isolement il est important pour nous
de leur apporter un peu de joie un peu
de réconfort au travers de la
gastronomie réunionnaise un moment de
convivialité se rassembler pour passer
un bon moment
un espoir partagé par jeannotro
conseillère départemental venus pour
l'occasion
je sais que vous êtes loin de chez vous
et que cela peut être difficile mais
nous sommes là pour vous grâce au
dispositif du département
pour vous soutenir et vous offrir le
meilleur je suis maman aussi et je suis
fière d'être là pour les accompagner en
tant que conseiller à départemental ça
se voit qu'il y a de la joie sur le
visage c'est gratifiant c'est très
important pour pour moi et pour tout le
monde c'est très important on les
accompagne depuis leur départ et
jusqu'ici on les accompagne toujours on
sera toujours là pour les accompagner
et à côté des samoussas et des bonbons
piments des Madras antillais et des
couronnes de fleurs polynésiennes car
aujourd'hui c'est tout l'outre-mer qui
fête les mamans
réunis à toutes les communautés
d'outre-mer c'est important parce que
souvent les personnes sont isolées et
ceux qui sont ceux du long terme ils ont
tendance à se refermer sur eux-mêmes
ils sont dans une détresse et je pense
que c'est important de se le but de
cette action et cette séquence c'est
faire en sorte qu'ils des rencontres qui
est de qui partage entre eux quand on
est dans l'ambiance créole comme il dit
je veux dire on a tendance à
s'ouvrir qu'en fait et là je veux dire
ça va créer des liens sociaux et par la
suite ça peut être important dans le
dans le parcours de soi parce qu'ils
vont apporter mutuellement leur soutien
à leur manière chacun la manière
et pour les soutenir le département a
choisi de prendre soin de ses dames au
programme des séances de bien-être
offertes par l'association Le Bon
Accueil l'objectif c'est que puisque
elles sont loin de la maison qui a pas
maman qui a papa qui a pas les tous les
enfants autour de soi on donne un petit
peu leur réconfort on se rappelle du
pays puisqu'on sait tous habillé
pratiquement en local pour se rappeler
que même si qu'on est loin de la maison
on est une grande famille puisqu'on se
conjoint chaque fois les dimanches pour
manger ensemble pour faire des choses
ensemble donc on est là et on veille les
uns sur les autres c'est vrai que on
passe par des moments difficiles donc ça
fait toujours du bien
et puis ça permet de se détendre un
petit peu aussi
[Musique]
et on y va
faire une pause dans le parcours du
combattant est essentiel pour ses
familles et pour toute ultra marin ça
passe aussi par la musique et bien sûr
par la table
sur la liste ça fait 8 mois que je suis
sur la liste j'attends toujours je suis
toujours dernier de la Lys
voilà quoi je sais pas quand je vais la
voir de retrouver des rayonnais qu'on
est loin
c'est magnifique ça donne de la force
super ma femme et mes enfants me
manquent et mes petits-enfants ça c'est
sûr mais enfin il faut aller de l'avant
cette année le département a invité
l'artiste Cédric Grondin du groupe
analyse technique
demande à moins de venir faire plaisir
aux mamans que ce soit réunionnaise ou
autre ici à Paris mais c'est une grande
fierté après maintenant humainement
parlant mais trouve que c'est un joli
geste quand même de donner un peu de
sourire un peu de bonheur il va faire
ici les mamans que de cette famille de
des choses que j'ai habitué depuis
longtemps donc s'il y a moyen que ma
venue
7 mois qu'azote le but est
et le but est largement atteint
l'ambiance battra son plein toute
l'après-midi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
premier Guyane alors
même si au nom de l'équipe du service
d'accompagnement de proximité de Paris
nous souhaitons à toutes les mamans une
bonne fête et de partager ce moment en
famille et d'être choyé et voilà plein
de bonnes choses à elle à toutes les
mamans qui sont loin de chez elle pour
savoir que on vous aime et on a voulu
vraiment vous montrer que vous allez
beaucoup d'importance on a passé une
super journée avec les malades du
transfert qui bénéficie des transferts
sanitaires et aussi avec tous les autres
malades de l'outre-mer donc on a passé
une super journée donc bonne fête à
toutes les mamans bonne fête à tous les
moments du monde et surtout les moments
de la Réunion et les moments malades à
Paris aussi bonne fête des mères à
toutes les mamans
soyons fiers de nous en tant que femme
en tant que mère bonne fête à toutes les
mamans
si vous avez une maladie
ne laissez pas tomber il faut aller de
l'avant parce que
[Musique]
il faut aller de l'avant voilà merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
de la mer